you know when i hear the story about you
coming to the door and you knock between
45 seconds in a minute i'm wondering if
you have any thoughts in hindsight or if
there's something else that could be
done to avoid this kind of stuff
probably the last two years so i i'll i
ran our major case unit before i went to
i had just transitioned to the the
parcel interdiction unit because i think
i was thinking man i probably got four
years left before i'm going to retire i
wanted to kind of bring slow things down
i'd already i already made entry in over
2000 search warrants and doors and i
thought to myself i thought
the luck's going to run out you know
it's just it's a numbers thing it's an
odds eventually i'm going to be in a
critical incident i don't want to be
so let's go ahead and start let's start
tapering this career off slowing down
because i've been going 100 miles an
hour for probably 15 of my 20 years
with search warrants and drugs and all
that and uh so i wanted to i wanted to
transition
and
the last two years i had constantly
thought about two things that bothered
me number one
eventually something's gonna happen but
the main thing was
as i matured as a person and as a dad
and all that once we would go through
these doors
you would have
three four five six-year-old kids
just terrified you know all of a sudden
you've got eight ten cops coming in with
guns screaming putting people on the
ground
and that started affecting me that
started making me go man this just ain't
worth it you know i we're traumatizing
these kids i can understand why they
grow up hating the police
you know you start thinking of all these
things and i'm going
we've got to do something different so
we started pulling people off we'd wait
till they leave their house they were at
a gas station barbershop wherever and
we'd start grabbing them up because it
it lowered our risk and it lowered their
risk and it lowered the trauma on these
kids so that was pretty big to me so we
had done that probably in 80 percent of
the cases the last two years i was up
there this wasn't my call we were
helping out so we did what they asked we
did what they asked us to do
if i could do it different if none of
the dynamics changed because people go
why did you have to do
why did you have to go there at 12 30 at
night if she wasn't a threat if she
wasn't the main target she was one of
the targets but she wasn't the main
target
and i try to explain to people because
word gets out so quick when you do a
warrant i mean it's even before the
internet we used to call it i'm probably
gonna get in trouble for this but i'm
gonna say it we used to call it the
ghetto net because it was like and it
doesn't matter if it's black or white it
was just if you hit a door
everybody's everybody knew man i mean
they just knew calls went out and so
when you do these type things where
where evidence might be at different
locations you do them simultaneous so
nothing is destroyed because that's what
you take into court uh glover glover's
car was registered to bring on his house
his bank account
when he bonded out of jail was there his
cell phone was registered there
everything was in her name or at her
house that was glovers so they wanted
that evidence to tie him in to that
house because they had pictures of him
coming there getting packages leaving
brianna taking him down to the trap
house dropping stuff off so that was the
impression brianna there was evidence
that she was involved in this stuff yeah
after the fact they pulled glover's
phone calls
and he's talking to his baby mama and he
said uh i need somebody to go to
briana's house and see if the cops miss
that money
and she was like oh you were letting her
hold your money why was she holding your
money you know she was mad
and he was like
well she holds a lot of people's money
it's just what she does so it was
was she slinging the dope i don't think
so i don't think physically she was
taking cylinder but she was part of the
organization in a peripheral way
bonded them out of jail letting them use
her address for stuff
um
holding money so she was tied into it
and people always go i hate this phrase
oh you think you're judge jury and
executioner and i'm going no i was just
trying to save my life and
this wasn't a payment for the crime
you know this wasn't that's not the
intent here uh so that that aggravates
me when people say that
i worry that uh people don't understand
there may not be solutions to these
things
so
you know you you look you've got someone
who's selling illegal drugs very
dangerous ones i mean what was suspected
of
fentanyl we believe fentanyl we know uh
uh meth
uh but yeah fentanyl he had the pills so
you know you can come out make an
argument about the legalization of drugs
but when you start getting into areas
about fentanyl you start getting harder
questions there are some libertarians
who are outright like no no people can
take whatever they want whatever they
want and i'm like you know i i get that
i get that but the question is
even still even then there's still got
to be some restrictions on
how much or or to children i mean you
got to prevent these things so
ultimately what ends up happening is
we've got a big we've got a big society
you've got people on the left people on
the right libertarians authoritarians
and everyone's got a different view
which means ultimately there's a
compromise the compromise we have right
now whether people like it or not is
that if somebody is illegally selling
very serious drugs we're going to stop
them i think most people the
overwhelming majority of people are
going to be like yeah i don't want
someone selling fentanyl in my area
because you don't know who's selling to
and it's an extremely dangerous drug
you go you go to local people and say
someone's selling you know marijuana or
something like that and they're gonna
roll their eyes and be like is this a
priority right now so the fentanyl
matters and if that's the case and there
are parents who want their neighborhoods
cleaned up and they don't want these
drugs around well then someone's got to
stop it but that means you're gonna have
to have police going and serving
warrants and what people didn't
understand like you said simultaneously
all at the same time
and relatively late for for strategic
reasons and also probably for safety
reasons for you've got less people who
are out and about things like that
then you have to contend with the fact
that people are allowed to defend
themselves in their homes no one's going
to take that away at least some people
are trying to and this means that you
get a perfect storm
a warrant is being served
nobody answers the door gets gets it's
you know kicked in and then the guy
shoots whether he was it whether it was
an accident or whether it was he didn't
know you were cops or did regardless the
conflict starts someone loses their life
you some people you know
these activists especially think there's
something that can be done or has to be
done and maybe i'm not saying we don't
investigate and try and figure out ways
to solve these problems but man some
people got to realize that
there may always be
this uh cause and effect that exists
within within this system at least as
we've defined it right now if people
have a right to keep and bear arms in
their home to defend themselves
and we expect police to shut down people
selling drugs very serious ones
you will get a situation like this and
people will people will die and there
can be uh you know i think one of the
officers he fired rounds that went to
other other apartments or something like
that yeah so the walls were co-joined
the
kitchen walls and that was one of the
that was one of the mistakes in this
thing not him shooting because
he thought we were getting executed at
that doorway you had metal and concrete
and the rapid shots and he thought oh
man he knew i'd gone down he thought
dude they're getting killed at the door
i got to do something yeah but the
problem is we weren't provided a map of
the layout of how that other apartment
was butted up yeah and from the outside
looking at it it doesn't look like it it
looks like they're separate
you know things right so if you hadn't
been in it or hadn't looked at the
actual layout so there were some
mistakes made don't get me wrong no for
sure for sure
what i mean to say is just in a bigger
picture i'm i'm reminded of this story
out of europe where i think it was in
denmark there was a mass shooter
and maybe it wasn't denmark it was a
country up in in europe and uh after the
shooting happened they mourned and then
did nothing and they said well sometimes
people are crazy and they get guns you
know what what are we supposed to do
right this this this was an it was an
aberration it wasn't
a fault of the system it was a fault of
sometimes people you know do bad things
and that's that's the challenge i see
with this i certainly think there's
there's uh ways to reform and there
needs to be
there there needs to be at least on a
criminal justice system very serious
reforms but my point is
if people are unwilling to confront the
system in any meaningful way and i mean
like the writers are not confronting in
any meaningful way the system doesn't
change in fact the writers are probably
only making it worse because now you're
going to get more regular people saying
more more weapons for the cops just shut
it all down they're going to say get
tougher get more aggressive then you're
going to get activists who are like my
friend was beaten by the cops well it's
because the community is demanding you
know these these things that shut down
you get people calling the mayor's
office the mayor calls the you know gets
the cops on the radio and says i don't
care what you do just shut down the
protest shut down the riots the cops say
okay get it done the people complain and
it's an endless cycle the the issue i
take with a lot of this is
these people who live in these cities
they're the ones who are voting in these
democratic politicians who don't care
about them right demanding of them
police action on crime
then when
when when the action on crime results in
some kind of um
accidents or a brutal event it's these
same people who are now complaining
about that event out marching in the
streets is one of the reasons i don't
want to live in these cities anymore
because it seems like these people don't
have a logical process in their mind as
to why these things are happening they
just say i don't understand why there's
got to be crime and i also don't
understand why you know cops are so mean
and i don't understand why people are
getting beaten and it's like
because people are shooting each other
and because you want the shooting to
stop so the cops go out and the cops are
scared of getting shot
and then some cops get shot and then
cops shoot back and then you complain
the cops shot back i'm like i don't know
well just like the majority of our
loudest mouth protesters and i'm not
talking about somebody really wanting
change walking with the sign
doing it the right way i'm talking about
the guys that were jumping on cars
taunting police
constantly in people's face i mean if
there was a cheerleading competition of
little girls
in downtown louisville during this it
was near the it was a little bit further
in so i think they thought it was safe
enough but it wasn't
and these guys were getting in these
parents and these kids face and saying
some will rape your kids i mean all
kinds of crazy stuff
and then they want to say the police are
the problem and all these guys who are
out here for reform and stuff that were
doing this all have had huge criminal
records there's like three of them that
have been killed since the riots started
that were the major drivers behind this
stuff two of them shot in the head and
no all three were shot in the head one
was in a carjacking so that may have
been uh accidental but the other two
were targeted hits and the funny thing
is that the rumor in the city was all
the people who disagree with the police
were going oh the police are out there
killing all the protesters and we're
going you kidding me because they caught
somebody on all of them you know well
there was uh in in lifestyle i mean in
ferguson i believe it was uh they found
a vehicle with a with someone killed in
the front seat i think that's what it
was it's been it's been a minute i don't
know if you've heard that story or
whatever it wasn't the cops who did it
although
the activists are pushing that there's a
conspiracy theater for a conspiracy
theory out of ferguson the police are
going around and executing the people
who organized the protest that's what
they're saying in louisville that's
crazy man it's like
a couple weeks probably a month ago now
there was a police chase a guy had shot
somebody robbed him shot him they're
chasing him
he wrecked out he eats his gun boom
kills himself
so they've got their body cameras on and
car cameras but
ever since our case before brianna
taylor
when our city investigated the thing
they they would release body cam footage
within 24 hours
and
but in our case they said since there
was no body cam they were like well we
can't talk about the case and i said
what's the difference in releasing body
cam that shows everything
or disputing the lies well they didn't
have an answer for it naturally but
because since then the state police took
over investigating because they were
like the protesters that was one of
their demands we don't want lmpd
investigating fine well let's state
please do it
so now the state police investigate
their policy is we don't release body
cam footage till we're ready until we've
investigated enough screw you we're
gonna do whatever we want
and
now they're saying and they were they
had three days of protest saying oh it's
a cover-up the police went up shot him
in the head he didn't shoot himself yep
so it's just it doesn't matter what you
do it's going to be
like like we said earlier there's that
fringe on both sides that are just crazy
on the right and the left that no matter
what you do it's not going to be right i
always try to uh clarify in that
that it's true but it seems to be the uh
the exception for the right and the rule
for the left yeah the the conservative
media apparatus tends to get stories
correct
the
liberal established media apparatus
tends to get stories wrong and it's
probably because these are big corporate
outlets that are driven by profit
whereas conservative outlets tend to be
driven by passion ideology or id or
ideology that is not that i am not
saying that one side is right or wrong
you know because a lot of people hear
that it's this is fascinating and
they're like you're saying the right is
good and i'm like
conservative news outlets are
you know small budget passion projects
where people are like i believe in this
i want to push a story out so they tend
to be
trying to follow the facts but with the
conservative perspective with
conservative commentary and opinion the
establishment's just like but whatever
gets us the clicks man yeah well truth
be told there's a lot of ideology behind
it as well with trying to get democrats
elected thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you